R
ASSISTANT TREASURY SECRETARY AND
SHE JOINS ME NOW.
MONICA, THE MIGRANTS IN THE
MILITARY CAMP IN MASSACHUSETTS,
THEY ARE MAD AT THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY WANTED TO STAY ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
THEY'RE ANGRY BECAUSE THEY WERE
DEPORTED.
CAN YOU BLAME THEM?
>> ISN'T IT A DELICIOUS TWIST IN
THIS ENTIRE STORY, JESSE, THAT
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME
INTO THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
BROKE OUR LAW TO GET HERE, AND
THEN WERE TRANSPORTED BY
GOVERNOR DESANTIS OUT OF
FLORIDA, WHICH IS NOT A
SANCTUARY STATE, TO THE
BEAUTIFUL ISLAND OF MARTHA'S
VINEYARD, THEY QUITE LIKED IT
THERE AND I CAN'T BLAME THEM.
THE VINEYARD IS GORGEOUS.
ESPECIALLY THIS TIME OF YEAR.
I ACTUALLY THINK, JESSE, THAT
GOVERNOR DESANTIS WAS INCREDIBLY
THOUGHTFUL IN MOVING THOSE
ILLEGALS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD AT
THE PEAK OF FALL FOLIAGE SEASON
SO THEY COULD ENJOY THE FALL
SEASON.
>> Jesse: LEAF KEEPERS FOR THE
VENEZUELA.
>> THEY ALL SAY WE ARE COMING
HERE TO WORK.
BUT THERE IS A PROCESS, A LEGAL
PROCESS FOR THEM IN ORDER TO DO
THAT.
THEY CHOSE A DINNER PATH.
A VERY DANGEROUS PATH BUT AN
ILLEGAL PATH THAT IS CAUSING
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
STRAIN ON THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING IS CATASTROPHIC ATTACK ON
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND ON THE
NATION IF DESANTIS HAD FLOWN
AWAY UNDERAGED GIRLS PRIVATE
ISLAND AND BACK TO MID-ATLANTIC
APARTMENT THEN MAYBE HE WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN SUED.
MAYBE IF HE HAD BILL CLINTON ON
THE PLANE WITH THE GIRLS, THEN
MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T HAVE DONE
ANYTHING.
OR MAYBE IF HE HAD JUST POINTED
A WEAPON AT THE KIDS, MAYBE,
MAYBE HE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN OFF
SCOT-FREE LISTENING TO SOUND
FROM HILLARY CLINTON.
HILLARY CLINTON COMPARING A
TRUMP REEL IT A HITLER RALLY.
I REMEMBER AS A YOUNG STUDENT
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW DID
YOUNG PEOPLE GET DRAWN IN BY
HITLER?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
I WOULD WATCH NEWS REELS AND SEE
THIS GUY UP THERE RANTING AND
RAVING AND PEOPLE SHOUTING AND
RAISING THEIR ARMS.
I THOUGHT WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
THESE PEOPLE?
WHY DID THEY BELIEVE THAT?
YOU SAW THE RALLY IN OHIO THE
OTHER NIGHT, TRUMP IS THERE
RANTING AND RAVING FOR MORE THAN
AN HOUR, AND YOU HAVE THESE ROWS
OF YOUNG MEN WITH THEIR ARMS
RAISED.
>> Jesse: DID YOU SEE ANY HIGHLY
HITLER SALUTES AT THE RALLY?
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME I'M
HEARING ABOUT IT AND IT HAPPENED
LAST WEEKEND.
>> I DID NOT AND I ACTUALLY
WATCHED THAT TRUMP RALLY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
JESSE, MRS. CLINTON CAN ALWAYS
BE COUNTED ON TO DELIVER REALLY
EPIC PROJECTION.
ACCUSING DONALD TRUMP OF WHAT
SHE/HERSELF AND HER PARTY ARE
GUILTY OF THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, TRUMP DID NOT DO
ANYTHING IN THAT RALLY.
HE HASN'T DOWN COUNTLESS TIMES
BEFORE AND COUNTLESS RALLIES.
IT IS A NORMAL PATRIOTIC MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN RALLY.
I WONDER IF MRS. CLINTON HAS
ACTUALLY SEEN A TRUMP RALLY
BEFORE.
THAT'S NUMBER TWO.
AND, NUMBER THREE, THE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY DID JUST GIVE
A HITLER SPEECH A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WITH RED BACK DROP AND TONE
AND RHETORIC CALLING HALF OF
AMERICA ENEMIES OF THE STATE.
THAT WAS ACTUALLY A FASCIST
SPEECH.
HILLARY CLINTON IS A MISTRESS OF
PROJECTION.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN CALLS HALF
THE COUNTRY FASCIST.
HILLARY CLINTON CALLS HALF THE
COUNTRIES NAZIS.
I THINK IT'S JUST MEAN AND, YOU
KNOW, IT'S REALLY MEAN AND
TRAGIC AND GOING TO GET SOMEONE
KILLED AND THAT LEADS